the whole world all of the ukrainians
heard that president putin
is
denying us the right to existence
in the same way as the nazis did not
give
the jews the right to existence
president putin does not
offer
the ukrainians to coexist with his
identity with his state
that's why we will not surrender
we understand that for us this is a
matter of survival
whether it's
reznikovs zalozni coleba or the
president's opinion it's not about the
surname it's about
this war being our war for existence
we are receiving humanitarian help and
political help not just from the western
countries but from some
gulf countries it's not just the gulf
but asian countries
that help is getting through to us
it is true
that the countries of those regions
are not currently helping us with arms
that we need to fight the aggressor they
are fighting other ways to help us
and we are very grateful to them for it
and the myth that is also
forced upon you that the u.s
and anyone else in the nato block do not
need ukraine it's also a lie they are
with us now look in the number of
countries who have joined and supported
and are supporting the resolution of the
un general assembly it's not just the us
it's not just the nato countries it's
not just the west there are many
countries from around the world each of
them
is finding a way to support ukraine
and we're grateful to them
a question from a latin russian speaker
edition
the volume is low well this is crazy the
question was about nuclear weapons that
is
crazy
uh that will bring the world into
catastrophe
if
what president putin is doing now the
war he started is the attack on the
global order then the use of nuclear
weapons will become an attack
against the humanity
all together so
we have to prevent it at any cost